I saw uh what's the biggest uh venue
we've done so far by yourself like like
biggest venue out there by myself oh and
this Android just be listening bro
what was the I don't know man I think
like by myself
probably not not four or five thousand
not that big yeah like four like four
thousand that's a big deal yeah like
four thousand that's a big deal I mean
it's four thousand is a big deal
that's a big deal it is but I mean
I mean I don't know it's a blessing
though bro you're like one album away
from doing an Amphitheater yeah like and
that's the crate man bro if I could tell
you something that I could tell you like
you'll be like okay yeah no it's coming
but like
you're gonna see though in in the next
like in the next month by that by the
beginning of next month so the stuff big
stuff when we get over here for the EP
no not period just period for the top of
next year
features tour like what are we talking
about both
so tell me about the song with Drake
that's coming yeah
man listen Hey listen tell them tell man
Drake needs to get in contact with me
I'm sure he already has it's coming at
the top of the Year nah I wish I would
like you know what's so crazy though bro
I'm I'm like the artist that I never
really I don't really talk to a lot of
artists I've noticed that about you I
feel like you are kind of like a like
I'm kind of like on an island yeah bro
like I don't see you doing like a lot of
collabs like yeah you're just kind of
doing your thing man I only do features
bro cause my labels like tell me that we
need to go get features and do features
and it's like all right cool but like I
really don't care for features bro I
don't that [ __ ] don't be I don't look
for it to be genuine or I don't look to
build no relationship but like you know
people only gonna call and want features
from you when they need you you know are
you actual because listen like you said
right like in music
we'll see people do records together
yeah and they might not have ever even
have met no or let alone like know each
other like
um are there any other artists that you
would consider actual friends yeah yeah
like um
it's a few like Glock great guy
Glock dirt
um who else
I rock with Osiris That's My Boy nice oh
cause he owe you any money no
nah crazy nah nah nah he don't he don't
and he's he's a super nice you might
have asked me a week ago
he said no he just squared up with me no
that was my boy though like I'm talking
about like real friends he might have a
gambling problem though yeah me too
though bro oh you do yeah bro I got a
real casino gambling he got like a
different gambling problem yeah I feel
like he I feel like he I feel like I
always see him gimbal anything
I mean shout out to him I met him and
his dad and they were like I haven't
yeah I haven't interviewed him in a
while but I remember the first time he
came to the station he had his pops with
him yeah and I didn't even know he was
from Jacksonville but I saw his dad and
I was like yeah you're from Florida
aren't you because I used to live in
Florida so I don't know what a Florida
[ __ ] works
I do it